uh so let's talk about the verdict so
obviously not guilty on all charges the
the thing that stunned me about the
controversy over this is that the
standard in american law is reasonable
doubt right it wasn't even that the
defendant in this case rittenhouse had
to prove that he did this in
self-defense he had to prove that there
was reasonable doubt that he might have
done this in self-defense there is no
human being with more than two neuronal
firing synapses who did not know this
was the case everybody knew that this
was the case if you had a prefrontal
cortex and you watched this trial for
more than 35 seconds you knew the
prosecution had nothing you knew all of
their witnesses were defense witnesses
you knew that all of the tape backed
written house's account it is
astonishing to me that there are still
members of the media claiming that for
some larger purpose written house had to
go to jail which by the way shows you
where they are because it was never
about the case and it's never about the
case right it's never about the
circumstances of the individual case
it's always about the broader narrative
that must be pushed and just like you
got to break a few eggs to make a
stalinist omelet you have to break a few
defendants in order to create social
justice according to these jerks and so
the fact that the jury stood up did the
right thing here is pretty impressive it
also i think underscores how much of a
threat they were under really because to
get them to not guilty that means that
that's either somebody had to be
convinced to go not guilty in which case
the entire jury had to bring you know
logic to bear or they knew not guilty
from the outset and they were waiting
because they didn't want to be run up a
flagpole for for the grave misstep of
somehow just saying the obvious right
away whatever the case may be uh it is
it is perfectly obvious that this jury
did the right thing which means of
course that the the the media and the
court of public opinion will deem that
the jury did the wrong thing it's it's
well that this is what i know what at
least cal written house ain't going to
jail right no this is this is what i
want to know though on that period where
they're just deliberating and
deliberating what on earth could you be
talking about were they
waiting for a mistrial were they trying
to kick the can to someone else or were
they do you think that they were
actually debating any of the facts of
the case
you know who the hell knows i have no
idea what was going on behind closed
doors it's hard to imagine that there
was a lot of debate going on behind
closed doors about the facts of the case
again all they had to get to is could a
reasonable person have a serious doubt
about whether kyle rittenhouse was
guilty in this case and the answer is
there is not a reasonable person on
earth who wouldn't have at least a
pretty serious doubt about whether he
was guilty in this particular case so
again if i had to guess i would think
that maybe the jury was like you know
we'll sit around for a couple of days
and have some pizza and beer and uh and
think about you know trying to kick the
can down the road a little bit maybe a
mistrial gets declared or or maybe at
the very least it looks like we spent
time considering the evidence but you
never know there could have been a
couple of hold outs who were convinced
to to go along with the not guilty
verdicts well whatever the outcome here
it's it's the media response that's
going to be so telling because you can
see the long faces in the media like
right now if we tune over to msnbc i
guarantee you that there are a bunch of
media figures who are decrying the
nature of america's criminal justice
system well if kyle rittenhouse had been
black and his victims had been white et
cetera et cetera or if kyle written
house has been black and his victims had
been black and all the rest of it the
reality is the prosecution never had a
case here they never had a case and by
the way if kyle rittenhouse had had been
a a black guy and his victims had been
black you never would have heard the
story right it never would have been a
story in the first place because that
sort of shooting takes place on a
regular basis in chicago the reason this
is a national story from the get-go is
because the media wanted a narrative and
the nerve that they wanted from the
get-go was evil white trump supporters
are out there shooting social justice
protesters and none of that was true it
just wasn't true from beginning to end
so good for the jury good for the judge
and i hope that written house i hope he
takes these uh the media members who are
declaring a murderer the people at
facebook who who are refusing to allow
anyone to donate to his legal defense
fund i hope he takes these bastards to
the cleaners i hope he makes out like a
bandit because people need to pay for
for lying about people to the point
where they end up in the middle of
murder trials for which they clearly
bear no culpability what about the
prosecutors do you think for instance
that they should have declared a
mistrial and what's going to happen to
these prosecutors now
i mean you know i think that
frankly i think the judge is probably
waiting to the verdict was so if this
came down as a as a hung jury i wouldn't
have been surprised if the judge said
okay miss trial with prejudice yeah and
he says listen you know we're gonna have
to retry this anyway but you don't get
to retry it you blew it mistrial with
prejudice uh it wouldn't have surprised
me if it'd come down guilty and he had
said mistrial uh if it came down with
acquittal then that solves all the
judge's problems right now he doesn't
have to do anything judges don't like
being reversed on repeal on appeal and
so you know i think what the judge is
probably concerned about is guilty
verdict he doesn't declare a mistrial
and then immediately this thing is
reversed on appeal because the
prosecutors were just involved in too
much shady behavior right here and by
the way it's very interesting to watch
who has shifted sides on how judges are
supposed to be in the courtroom so the
left loves judges who are very
pro-defendant except when they don't
like the defendant that that seems to be
the the common way of the world here so
this judge was this judge was one of
their favorites for years
because he was famously pro-defendant
the minute they don't like the guy in
the dock then all of a sudden this judge
is a rabid right-wing nutcase who plays
god save the usa god bless the usa on
his cell phone so it's it's pretty
astonishing michael you know what i want
to take a moment and uh and if you don't
mind play a couple of the clips from
this trial because i think it really is
indicative of of all this so let's start
by the way i i just got in the chair so
i literally did not hear even the audio
of the of the judge
announcing the verdict so let's start
with that cause i'd actually like to
hear it
nope we don't have that one yet okay
fine so
but what we do have zip recruiter i
think
that's the first count of the
information joseph rosenbaum we need the
jury to find the defendant kyle h
rittenhouse not guilty
as to the second count of the
information richard mcginnis we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the third count of the information
unknown mail we the jury find the
defendant kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
as to the fourth count of the
information anthony huber we the jury
find the defendant kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
as to the fifth count of the information
gage rose courts we the jury find the
defendant kyle avery kyle h rittenhouse
not guilty
members of the jury are these your
unanimous verdicts
is there anyone who does not agree with
the verdicts as read
you wish the jury
okay so
the first time i'm seeing that clip so
let me just point one thing out right
written house there he breaks down in
tears he looks exactly the same crying
when he is declared not guilty as he did
on the stand now remember when he broke
down on the stand we got a bevy of blue
check saying it was fake it was made up
that's not what he looks like when he's
crying it's all inauthentic so was he
faking this time too is he faking when
he's declared not guilty he's faking the
tears for the camera there or are you
guys just a bunch of vulturous bastards
hang around to pick on people you don't
like simply because they don't have the
same political prerequisites that you do
and don't wish to uphold the lie that
career criminals child molesters running
around the streets of kenosha wisconsin
are heroes if you reject that premise
then you have to you have to be put up
as some sort of evil villain a written
house was was not guilty from the get-go
the tape showed it i waited until the
trial began because i thought maybe the
prosecution has something i don't know
about that's what i do with criminal
trials i'm i'm more concerned about
being right than being first but as soon
as it became clear the prosecution had
nothing this was a clear-cut case at
that point it was absolutely clear-cut i
thought it was clear-cut based on the
original tape but then you wait and you
see okay fine maybe they've got
something i don't know about well they
didn't they not only didn't have
anything that we didn't know about they
were withholding evidence from the
defense they were literally not giving
over the evidence they had to give over
to the defense it's absolutely
unbelievable how bad the prosecution was
in this case and and all of this there
there's not a single iota of this case
that didn't back written how it's his
case that's the part that's so amazing
how is this even controversial